thank you so much for joining us fall is
in the air and our community has enjoyed
the gilchrist orchard for over 90 years
and fortunately with all that's going on
2020 is no exception
rocky is live at the pumpkin patch just
show us how they're all
keeping the fall spirit alive hey rocky
hey you guys yes we are keeping this the
fall spirit alive right mark yes we are
this is your family business here you
guys have been here for years how does
it feel to finally be back in season
uh it's great this is the time we
planned for all year yeah and
obviously let's let's walk and talk
because there's so much to see here
obviously things are a little different
this year and i'm new to town so
what could people enjoy here on a
regular
fall season well our regular fall season
we'll have our hay rides
and uh there's a straw maze that's open
neither one of those are available this
year
but everything else is available so
there's the pumpkins the donuts the
caramel apples all that stuff is still
available okay i know we're looking at
some b-roll right
now because you guys opened up this
weekend correct yes
and that is a big season for you and
you're open from tuesdays it's
a sneak peek today you guys are closed
but you guys invited us in so thank you
but you're open from tuesdays to sundays
from 7am to 2pm
close tuesdays thursdays saturdays and
sundays
dang okay thank you for clearing that up
and what can people
come down and enjoy all day so they come
down if you
like it it's really hot right now so
that's why you say if you want this
the fall experience come in the morning
good idea if you want the summer
experience there's less people about
noon
on but if you can take it there's less
people
okay and then fall safety of course we
have to keep that in mind what do people
need to keep in mind for that
wear your mask when you come in when
you're checking out and even in the
pumpkin patch keep
social distancing okay well we can do
that coming up later in the four o'clock
we're gonna see what else
we have in store because other than
pumpkins we've got donuts
and other things to enjoy here too so
we're gonna go take exploration
i'll send it back to you thanks rocky
those donuts up there they are iconic
everybody knows about the guild cruiser
donuts we'll check back bring them back
during the 4pm newscast this is